I saw your post on turkey tail mushrooms. Do you have that available to add to our protocol?
It is one of the six mushrooms in rice coffee, so rice coffee is a brand of coffee that is a
mushroom coffee. Would you recommend using that to get the turkey tail? So rice coffee has
very like six different mushrooms in the coffee and you're putting a tablespoon in your coffee
as a instant coffee and it is organic, so you could certainly use that.
But remember, if I did your cheek swab and it didn't say you needed to use turkey tail mushrooms,
then you don't need it. But if you feel like you want to add turkey tail mushrooms to your protocol,
you could use rice coffee. We have our turkey tail complete product, our cutters clinic,
turkey tail product also. Also another good brand is the host defense turkey tail.
Product, those are the two good products that we have in the store that I like the best.
But you could use rice coffee if you like that. That's fine too.
There really isn't a downside to adding mushrooms to anybody's protocol. So
the only caveat to that would be if you have brain cancer, you don't want to add lions made.
But short of having brain cancer, there really isn't any negatives to adding any of the mushrooms
to your protocol, any of the mushrooms. So yeah, that would be just fine.